hey guys how's it going so I wanted to
show you guys the setup that I finally
have with my MacBook Pro with touch bar
I did a little vlog showing you guys a
little bit of this do you guys got upset
because it was a vlog of my day but then
at the end I talked about the MacBook
setup so this is a dedicated video
because a lot of you guys wanted to see
what I had going on I also showed you
this bag this was my big bag of
emergency cords that basically has
everything that I would need to charge
to transfer I've got extra batteries
I've got tripods I've got all kinds of
things in here so a lot of you guys
thought that these cords were everything
that I need to make this MacBook Pro
actually functionable
so far I've paired it down to one USB C
hub a USB C to thunderbolt adapter a USB
C powered hard drive and the fourth
chord I'm using as my charging port so
with this single USBC hub I basically
have all of the bases covered and I
don't necessarily need anything else if
I'm just out and about using my computer
on a normal basis but if I'm at my desk
I do need to have a few extra things so
I'm using one of the Apple monitors
unfortunately Apple isn't really going
to be in the monitor market anymore
which is really upsetting because it's
so beautiful the one that they announced
at the keynote was the LG 5k display I
didn't really like look of it and it
wasn't even available to order until
December they did have a 4k one
available but I'm going to get one I'm
going to have to get the 5k but for now
this is the monitor that I already have
so with this monitor connected it gives
me several other USB ports a firewire a
thunderbolt and Ethernet cable port just
in case I need it that alleviates
dongles right there it's not as bad as
you guys think I know it's a little bit
unnecessary a lot of people were super
upset claiming that the MacBook is no
longer control Mac not saying I had a
percent disagree with you it definitely
sucks to have to have extra dongles to
get things done easily as you did before
with these ports that were already in
your computer for the most part I'm in
love with this MacBook so you're going
to get one dongle this is the one to get
it's the USB C to USB so if you're ever
in a bind to really like oh man I really
need something always have this one with
you so on the main Apple monitor that's
where I edit and that's basically a full
screen Final Cut Pro setup so by my
favorite touch bar feature so far is
adjusting audio on the
I in Final Cut Pro you adjust it over
here and it changes right here on the
timeline and on the MacBook I have other
things going on like Google searches and
iMessage it really whatever else I would
be doing but this allows me to have
Final Cut open at all times and it's
just it's great it's beautiful and the
Bluetooth keyboard and the mouse just
connected directly to my macbook so that
alleviates some chords right there the
mousepad that I'm using is actually a
razer mousepad and i really really like
it because i have an extremely
reflective desk if you haven't noticed
so I really like offsetting that with
this black mousepad and next to it I've
got a over here we've got my little
apple watch dock that's actually plugged
into the monitor so that's pretty much
always connected and really that's
pretty much it I feel like it was a lot
more concerned with how this was all
going to work out I was a little bit
worried that I really would be needing
this entire bag of cords and dongles and
everything but so far it's been pretty
simple let me know what you guys think I
hope that you guys enjoyed this video
just a quick little desk tour I guess
you could say I really felt bad because
people were complaining and saying that
my last video was clickbait but it was
it was a vlog and I just was trying to
take you through my day one thing that I
really like to do is show how I use
things throughout my day not necessarily
just in sort of a sit-down setting I
like it to be casual I like it to be
real so maybe that's not for you but if
it is cool welcome to my channel we get
really crazy here or not at all I will
tell you I love having the touch ID it's
like magic you know together well it
started the progression of moving
towards using my macbook pro with touch
bar as my main computer but the problem
is as most of everyone has been talking
about is the dongle gate my dongle gate
has currently already started I'm
currently using one of the monitors that
I used to use in my trashcan Mac which
not too long ago maybe like